okay exciting thing on December 9th and
10th in Seattle Washington we're gonna
be holding the first pod con a
convention and Conference of podcasters
and people who love podcasts we're doing
it in partnership with Joseph Fink and
Jeffrey Cranor from welcome to night
Vale and Alice's and Dead and the
McElroy brothers of lots of different
podcasts John and I will be there doing
a bunch of stuff including a live dear
Hank and John but in order to know the
full extent of what we can afford to do
we're launching it with an IndieGoGo
crowdfunding campaign you can find that
right now at pod calm calm there are
several different ticket levels and also
a bunch of perks for people who can't
attend including an audio collection of
absolutely everything that happens at
the event pod con for people who love
podcasts coming to Seattle in December I
hope we will hear you there and also see
you there and now on with the pod hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John
there's that first thing with Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where two brothers give you advice
that is dubious and see your questions
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon I'm Hank
this is John how are you John I'm all
right
you know I Hank I have to tell you the
honest truth which is that there is a
little bit of me that wishes that in
addition to having like opted out of
Twitter I could just not have my daily
thoughts consumed so much by certain
political leaders in the United States
but this is the reality that I'm living
in right now and I'm just trying to make
a go of it here at Grover Cleveland High
School do you get that reference I don't
I do now my god it's to the best movie
ever I can't believe you've never seen
Rushmore I have seen it I think oh my
god even the idea that you don't know
whether you've seen Rushmore is deeply
upsetting to me that's honestly worse
than if you just hadn't seen it I accept
that
that that is the case do you know you
want to know what's happening in my life
John I do very much a young man who
lives in my home he's six months old
mm-hmm has learned how to grab my
glasses and throw them
raus the room oh yeah that's yeah he
he'll put them anywhere in his mouth if
there's poop nearby he'll try to get it
in that and so I basically I'm getting
ready for needing multiple pairs of
glasses this podcast unfortunately it's
not brought to you by Warby Parker but
there may be some some dealings with
them in the future and by dealings I
mean I'm gonna maybe buy some glasses
from them uh I don't know that like
having 17 pairs of backup glasses is the
best strategy I think you just got to
keep your face out of your kids mall
that's unpossible he is too cute for
that he has a it's a ma that needs a
face in it all right
I don't have any I don't have any short
poems for today because I want to leave
plenty of time at the end from the end
for the incredibly exciting news from
AFC Wimbledon so let's just jump right
in to questions from our listeners Hank
alright this one is from Amanda who asks
dear Hank and John it's deah so she
wanted me to say it that way and I did
I'm currently a private tutor in
elementary aged kids and some of my
students don't even have grammar
instruction but those who do tend to
struggle with it many ask why they need
to know it I tell them that it is
important to understand how English
works as a language because it will make
their reading and writing skills better
but honestly I'm mostly just trying to
get them focused on their work my
question is this I'm skipping some stuff
how does technology change what grammar
and for that matter
spelling and writing instruction look
like in schools and how do I convince my
students that it's important yours
Amanda I think that grammar is important
because what we're trying to do when we
communicate with each other is
communicate clearly and technology can
help with that but it can't construct a
sentence for you yet there's something
about a really well-constructed clear
concise transparent sentence that is
just absolutely magical and makes you
want to do whatever the sentence tells
you to do and that to me is the secret
of language if in this world if you can
write a good email you can get a lot of
things done I definitely think that
I think that that is a hundred percent
and I think that when I'm looking to
hire someone I'm looking at writing
skills even when the job is not involve
a lot of writing like I'm reading a
cover letter like I'm looking at that
and I know that like that is important
but I don't know that it's necessary for
me to know how like to be able to
diagram a sentence for me to be able to
write a good one
I don't know that it's necessary for you
to be able to diagram a sentence but you
do need to understand what different
parts of sentences do and how they do it
and why they have it and until that
stuff is just kind of like deeply
ingrained and it is second nature you do
have to think about it you know like I
was talking with Henry yesterday about
verbs and I was like so what is a verb
Henry and he said a verb is something
you can do and I thought that was an
interesting idea but then I was like all
right so what's the verb in the sentence
Henry is awesome and he was like well I
don't know and understanding like what
is what is does as a verb and what it
doesn't do I think it's actually kind of
important yeah I I agree that look when
I was an elementary school student I
thought that grammar was the stupidest
thing in the world second only to
algebra but I now and I think a lot
about it now and not only because I
write books but also because I write
emails and love letters and lots of
other things yeah and I and you gotta
know where that that comma goes and if
you understand where the cause is then
that really helps with where that comma
goes all right hey I can't believe you
didn't ask the following question first
because it is obviously the most
critical question we received this week
it's from Alicia or Alicia or Alicia I
don't know how to pronounce your name I
apologize I'm just gonna call you Ryan
dear Green brothers I was born on an
airplane and before you ask no not a
commercial airplane but a small
passenger plane specifically a piper
Seneca 3 this is the only sentence in
the email Hank that specifically seeks
to explain the circumstances in which
this birth happened which I find
fascinating I'm looking at
of piper Seneca Three's John and I gotta
tell you there's not a lot of room to
have a baby on there okay
the other thing about a piper Seneca 3
Hank that really struck me is that it
doesn't have that big of a range like
it's not like you can get in a piper
Seneca 3 and fly around for five hours
so like Wayne when the person who
birthed you got on that plane were they
already in labor like was that the goal
or was it an incredibly short labor or
alternately like were they already in
labor and they were trying to like get
somewhere like maybe for instance a
hospital where you could have had a
safer delivery but in the end it all
went down in the piper Seneca 3 like the
piper Seneca 3 it just it it's a very
very small plane yeah so that so I've
looked up the performance specs for the
piper Seneca 3 has a range of about a
thousand miles and in a cruise speed of
around 216 miles per hour so we're
talking about tops you could be in that
plane for five hours before it had to
land so you're in and if you're coming
so you're never gonna be more than two
and a half hours from an airport so if
you if you you your mother went into
labor right in the worst possible time
right you would have had like in like
you turn around and you could go back or
you could go all the way to the final
destination it happened fast this was a
fast and this happens sometimes
sometimes you're like oh my water broke
and then you're like at there's a baby
head coming out of me like it's unusual
and it's a good thing usually when it
happens but usually you're not on an
airplane at the time so we think we've
gotten to for the most part to the
bottom of it it was a quick labor it was
a quick labor but I do have a follow-up
question which is that this plane only
seats five passengers if I have and but
but it landed with six I was gonna say
like I'm such a I feel very strongly
about plane safety as you know
Hank and I feel very strongly that you
should follow but the rules of plane
safety even if those rules don't
necessarily make sense and I would be
freaking out if we started with five
passengers and for the last hour we had
we had six because I would be like that
is that is the piper Seneca three is not
it is not designed for this new creature
I did not sign on for a flight with this
thing all right anyway for a few years
now I've been trying to find the plane
that I was born on as it is one of my
life goals I haven't come very close
until about two months ago when I
received more information about it the
info I got was the plane's tag number
which you can search up online and you
can find out where it is now here's my
problem the tag number I got says the
plane that crashed a year before I was
born
Oh which which she then dismisses
immediately by saying obviously that's
not possible seeing as I was born on it
but I mean or is it unless unless it's
totally possible and you're living in an
alternate timeline and things just got
really we or or sometimes plane curtain
planes crash and then they fix them
sometimes it's not like something like
it's like a like it's just like a car
crash sometimes you can sometimes it can
be okay yeah I one of my other rules
when it comes to plane safety is that I
do not get on previously crashed planes
so John let me tell you a quick story I
know they were still in the middle of
this question but when I was in Haiti I
got in an airplane it was about the size
of a piper Seneca six it or three it
might even have been one and but I think
smaller even and I got in the plane and
I was like hey what's up pilot man and I
was like sitting in the passenger seat
cuz like that's how small this thing was
so just doing my best to not touch
anything because like I had a steering
wheel in front of me terrif yeah and and
I was like bantering with the pilot and
I was like so how are you been doing
this and he was like you know decades
and I was like and obviously like never
crashed so I shouldn't worry about
anything it was like actually and I was
like no don't say actually don't do that
and he had his plane had crashed like
two weeks ago and he had that night out
not that plane but the plane that he was
flying and it like Healey showed me the
missing teeth
his mouth that held out in the plane
crash that he had recently been in well
was it a stormy debt tell me all the
reasons why that day is different from
this one like all of the end of it was a
fire it was turned out to be a very
beautiful and uncomfortable flight that
I did not puke on at all I'm working at
the interior of a piper Seneca 3 and
Hank let me tell you I would not want to
give birth inside of this aircraft oh
man we're gonna have to put up a bunch
of pictures on the patreon aren't we on
the other hand it's a nice plane now I
personally do not believe in flying twin
planes with two propellers it's just
it's not in my it's not one of mine it's
not it I don't actually I don't even
want to talk about this anymore let's
move on okay upon more searching I may
have possibly found my plane but it is
now owned by an elderly man and I found
him not via the airplane tag number
search but through creepy googling
should I contact this man and I asked
him about the plane and explain how I
got his phone number or is that too
weird just trying to find my plane
Alicia
first off Alicia as far as I could tell
the one thing that we know for sure in
this story is that this is not your
plane definitely the case it is an old
man's plane it's see it's either an old
man's plane or it is a plane that's it
in like lost in the mountains of Alaska
then you were born on six months after
it was lost I suspect that it is the old
man's plane and I am NOT an old man
myself he said hopefully I don't know
how old this elderly man is he didn't
explain it's possible that you're 16 and
you think 39 is elderly but if I were
the owner of a piper Seneca three which
is one of the things I hope most in life
never to become I would be absolutely
delighted if a child who was born on my
aircraft wanted to come and see the
plane on which she was born but if you
do that I have one piece of advice which
is to bring a portable handheld
backlight so you can maybe find some
amniotic
and see exactly the spot where you came
out I mean we were having so much fun
and then you made it really gross I
think that'd be fun I think it'd be
really interesting no it is don't like
she's a miracle maybe don't show the
elderly man what you find
here's I I don't think I I think the
elderly man is gonna be psyched about
this 999 times out of a hundred and then
like the 1% of the time it's just like a
crotchety old person who it was gonna be
miserable about whatever you mentioned
to them
I wouldn't necessarily bring up the
creepy googling part I would just be
like uh I noticed you have my plane and
then if they ask you can just be like oh
I was just searching on the Internet old
people don't really know what the
internet is right about that
totally yeah it's not gonna know how
creepy it was just be like guys the
Internet
I just looked you up on on and then make
up a name of a website like Cobb Euler
that's a pretty good name for a website
is that is copular comm taken if not it
could be kinda be home for our new
Google's our new search business called
Igor comm is available Hank cula our
comm cog Euler comm the hot new website
from the green brothers it's where you
can find all the year lost planes Kobe
or comm is a great idea for that sounds
like a proper made-up company well I'm
pleased what does cop you Cabul are mean
in Spanish must must be nothing or else
it'll be taken what about copula I have
a guess at what copy alarm means in
Spanish ah I'm gonna look it up
it's copulate it's to copulate okay well
we're not doing this is Cobb you are
which is a completely different company
and it's a made-up word like like you
know riper or lift with a why it's just
a made-up company named Cobb you are
it's our it's our exciting new it's our
exciting new e-commerce project that we
can't tell you about just getting it
redirects to dftba.com
boom
this is the fifth question comes from
Drew who asks dear Hank and John this
June I'm marrying the love of my life
however we're having difficulty finding
great items for our registry what are
some amazing items you wish you had on
your registry when you got married also
why does dftba not have a registry
option thanks for bringing up our
e-commerce systems and by dftba I'm sure
you mean Kat Mueller comm thousand cows
drew Hank what do you like the things
that you got for your wedding are there
any of them that when you look at them
you think about the person who got you
that fondly because that's what you
really want like you want something that
it's not just like useful it also
connects you to somebody you love John
your reach and you're reaching
terrifyingly close to a thing about me
that I'm not super proud of which is
that I don't really think about things
enough for after you know ten years of
marriage to have any connection to any
of the items that I was given for my
registry including the ones that you
purchased for me oh I have no idea what
I got you don't feel weird about that
but do you remember like uh are there
things that you got for your wedding
that have proven useful to you or do you
not even know what you got at your
wedding versus like what you just bought
at Target six months later I know that I
got my silverware and my plates for my
wedding and we do use those all the time
I don't know who bought them but I am
glad to have them and they've lasted us
a long time yeah things have broken but
not so much that we can't that like we
don't have like a good and full set and
they were purchased at Macy's and we had
a registry at Macy's and I believe
that's where our knives came from as
well I will say a very good knife is
something that something that I didn't
get for a long time including for my
registry and I wish I had gotten on my
registry yes my most used appliance in
the house is my SodaStream which turns
regular water into carbonated water so
they don't have to be a carbonated water
and I would tell that's it don't tell
that to our future sponsors Lacroix yes
well either you get the excellent
Pomplamoose flavoring if you you can't
get that without Lacroix okay and that's
what that's their new tagline
if you have a SodaStream you're never
gonna get Pomplamoose without lacroix
and brought to you by Lucroy everyone
it's surprising to me that you don't
work in advertising but ok so I do I do
work in advertising I just do it badly I
think I agree the not you're like silver
silverware if you're a fancy person with
actual silver like that that in my
experience you never end up using but
your everyday cutlery your everyday
plates if you don't own that stuff
already you can register for that stuff
people will be happy to get it for you
probably hopefully if you do own that
stuff then you might be in a situation
where you don't actually need to
register for that much stuff in which
case maybe you could just raise money
for your honeymoon if you want to go on
a nice honeymoon yeah or raise money for
a charity that you care a lot about like
have people donate you know like farm
animals through effort international or
something like that I I've known a lot
of people who do that and I think that's
really cool the gift that I receive tank
that has meant the most to me through
the years mm-hmm
so Sarah's got an uncle uncle backs
uncle Baxter and Baxter is an amazing
guy and we received these monic we
didn't register for them
we just received them one day these
monogrammed highball glasses that you
know you drink like mixed drinks out of
and I was never a person who like I
never even knew what a highball glass
was you know like when I wanted to make
a mixed drink I drank it out of my alvin
and the chipmunks glass from 1986 just
like a regular American you know but
when I got these monogrammed highball
glasses that have like our shared
initials s and JG on them and by the way
I should add that uncle Beck's did not
get us like four monogrammed highball
glasses or eight he got us like 40 and
I'm not exaggerating
in fact I've broken a lot of them over
the years and the great thing is that
there's this like box that essentially
has an infinite supply in our basement
there is a box with an infinite supply
of monogrammed highball glasses and
every time I drink a glass of scotch or
something unlike man uncle box he knew
the person I was going to become before
I did
I'm saying I like the idea of an
infinite supply of something like yeah
like something that might not any
disliked look you never have to worry
about this again you're just right you'd
like you could you could break one of
these everyday like just like like for
your drink every time
I'll how about other and though you
don't want to throw your drink every
time I mean we would run out of them if
we did that but yes I understand you're
correct in theory I you know what
occurred to me is what like what if I
just what if I did what if I just
registered for stuff on Amazon pantry
like paper towels and and baked beans
like the things that I really need no
because the whole idea of the wedding
registry is that it's stuff that lasts
like stuff that you buy once in your
life anyway that's my understanding of
it like and that guy can't like that
although I have to say we just got we
just got rid of our plates that we've
had for 10 years because I had to
photograph my food every day for 100
days and by like day 98 Sarah was like
we're getting new plates and I was like
why and she was like our plates are
horrible and they were they were kind of
horrible so we've got all new plates
Hank I've got a new question for you
okay it comes from Sam
he writes Dear John and Hank what are
your thoughts on the word content in
reference to internet video I've heard a
lot of people dislike it but I'm not
totally sure why is it because it
commercializes art are art and content
different jenga Sam
what a great sign on it is Jenga
something you say while playing Jenga
like every time you put the thing on the
top you're like Jenga like uno or
something or is that just I'm not
totally sure it's been a while I gotta
confess it's been some time since I
played Jenga and it's been even longer
since I played Jenga by the official
Jenga rules Jenga is a really great
made-up word like like popular that's it
it's not as good as coffee or maybe Cobb
Euler will be our version of Jenga but
it's made out of corn that's pretty good
it's not great but it's headed in the
right direction
maybe Cobb Euler will just be a place
where we sell high-quality sweet corn
year-round yeah it's like Court of the
Month Club popular corn
the Month Club and copier comm oh you're
gonna get corn from every country in the
world you're gonna get artisanal
heirloom corns I mean and it's gonna be
so sustainable it's gonna be so
sustainably farmed and then the only
part of it is that's not sustainable is
the part where we put it on a plane
braid it to you and ship it to you
overnight in a totally unsustainable
package yeah yeah but is this farming
part yeah I'm completely organic
it was doing Kazakhstan it was
organically very sustainably farmed in
Kazakhstan and then we put it on a plane
and flew it to America and we put it on
another plane and flew it to your house
ha ha oh my god Cobb columns the
question of your corner of the month
Hank finally we have a business that's
gonna not lose money sorry what was the
question I don't remember
Oh content yeah I don't know I get so I
just think that it's a it's a
commodification which people don't like
to have their work commoditized which is
something that we are finding out more
and more when I think it's too modified
Kumada yeah sure I believe you when you
take something and you're like this was
once something that you worked really
hard on and now it's like now pull it
put it in a box with a thousand of it
look exactly the same
you're like oh I guess I'm not that
important like I'm just I'm just like a
cog in this machine and that is kind of
what content sounds like and you hear
about content farms where people just
sort of just churn out words that can
then be advertised against for the
lowest price possible so that so that so
that you know we can try and keep this
economy going on the internet which is a
hard place to make an economy work but
it is content I just think that it's
kind of become a come to mean a slightly
different thing and that can give people
a bad feeling I don't mind it yeah my
feeling is that well I always think
about whenever I think about the word
content I try to hear it for the first
time and if I were hearing it for the
first time I would be like oh my god
barf and because I remember when I first
started dating Sarah I knew nothing
about contemporary art I you know like
read a couple of books to try to look
like I wasn't it
it when I was hanging out with Sarah
because she worked at an art gallery and
all of her friends were a lot of her
friends were art people and like I knew
nothing of that world it was totally
foreign to me and when I would hear them
talk I noticed that when they were
talking about like an individual work of
art they would always say this piece and
I would just feel like well that's dumb
why don't you just say like this artwork
or this thing or this work of art why is
it always this piece and then when they
were talking about like an art like a
group of pieces they would say like this
artists work and I would just be like oh
come on like this distinction between
work and piece is so annoying and weird
and gross in particular and like it sort
of exists to create a group of people
that are inside and a group of people
that are outside and yeah so I I totally
get it because when I hear the word
content for the first time or if I can
sound live if I can like put myself in
the mindset of hearing for the first
time I would be like ooh but now I'm so
used to saying it you know that we make
like content online Hank what are you
what not what what is that noise in the
background I don't know I think it's
just on the phone I don't think that
it's on the recording it sounds like
you're shuffling cards in my ear yeah I
hear it too
I don't know okay yeah are you shuffling
cards nope I'm just sitting here because
I'm trying to like I'm wondering are you
playing with me right now are you
playing a game with me is this like a is
this like the thing where - they're
Alicia's parents made up a tag number of
a crashed plane and said but that's
where she was born you're gonna have to
do something you're gonna have to do
some you're gonna have to do some
bleeping okay I don't know what it is
you know what I'm gonna try not to call
what I make content anymore I'm just
gonna call it well like all of the
things of the lingo of my industry that
is not the one that bothers me so much
like I hate influencers so much more
yeah and I hate industry actually I
really hate like
industry like what just being like
you're the little pond in which like you
think that you are a big fish because
the pond is so incredibly little eat it
boy
yeah III also like there was a while
when people were using the phrase weblab
ready and I was just like okay I'm gonna
leave and never come back
but I love celebrity I mean I me I am a
internet sensation
so celebrity I mean just the idea like
so what do you do for a living well I'm
a celebrity I'm sorry did you say that
you're a softie no I did not
unfortunately I would like to be a
celebrity when I grow up but right now
I'm just a celebrity today's podcast is
brought to you by celebrities
celebrities just just trying to harvest
some content in this sweet sweet
industry five guesses also brought to
you by the piper Seneca 3 the range of
1,000 miles a night of cruising speed of
216 miles per hour it is possible to go
into labor and also have a baby before
you land and today's vodkas is also
brought to you by Cobb Euler calm Cobb
Euler calm your number one source for
the corner of the Month Club
and finally podcast is brought to you by
an infinite supply of highball glasses
an infinite supply of highball glasses
supplied by uncle backs oh man have
you've met my uncle backs haven't you I
think it's possible
yes great alright Hank let's get to a
couple more questions
geez Louise you really got me going
there oh yeah I'll never get I'll never
get off of celebrity I I feel like we
have cut out something very special
so I by the way I have to I just really
quickly I have to say I did not coin the
word celebrity I don't want to be
credited with I wish that I were that
genius but I don't
I don't know where it came from I don't
know how it came to me but I know for a
fact that I did not think of it I am not
nearly clever enough to think of
celebrities so just to be clear about
that all right Hank
Jana moves on to an extremely serious
question because I've had enough jokey
jokey questions okay
okay ready yes all right this question
comes from Maggie your writes Dear John
and Hank I'm 25 and I need dating advice
and who else do I turn to but to married
men in their late 30s late 30s I'm 37 oh
gosh yeah you're in your late 30s buddy
I mean the issue actually the surprise
to me in that in that question was not
that I'm in my late 30s but that I have
a younger brother in his late thirties I
feel no alarm whatsoever it being in my
own weight 30s but the thought that
you're in your way is upsetting to me
I've gone on a few dates with this guy I
met online I guess that's how people
meet now and we've had a lot of fun and
I like him and I think he likes me and
but he's super fit and I'm not oh like
he has a six-pack who even has a 6
pattern even real right I agree it's
take it from a guy who just exercised
for a hundred days in a row it is not
even real he has a six-pack and I eat
tacos like all the time also I hope
she's exaggerating slightly I mean if
she's eating tacos like all the time
that is some a bit of a concern like
tacos what you want you want to make
sure you get a balanced diet like
sometimes you gotta have a burrito I
generally feel good about myself and my
body but this has caused me to develop a
complex of sorts do you have any advice
to help me get over myself and just have
fun dating hopefully not forever alone
Maggie Maggie judging from your email I
think the reason that you're getting
along well with this dude is that you're
incredibly charming and funny and yeah
and you should own that and that's
awesome I have very rarely been more
impressed by an email get a lot of them
too
I yeah I it's interesting to think that
like that
being fit might be a detriment to some
relationships like if you're too hot
people are gonna be like this I'm gonna
work out I'm sorry your there's clearly
something that's there's a there's a
difference here and I'm I'm out I'm a
taco fan so I'm just gonna go also Hank
I mean I am totally coming at this
question from the perspective of a guy
and also like an old guy who's been
married for a long time but like it
this the question presupposes that
there's only one kind of hot yeah that
there's only like one sort of attractive
and like that's just not true like yeah
there's all kinds of different
attractive and all front for different
people you know and and so like I think
you kind of gotta let go of it I
understand like I think probably the if
you're having like I I think it comes
from the outside social order right like
the social order is so specific about
what constitutes hot and oh my god
six-packs they're so rare and hot and
Wow a six-pack but like you know not
everybody likes six-packs hopefully not
everyone requires six-packs at least
that's definitely that's definitely
clear and true and for sure yeah we
could say with certainty but not
everybody sees a six-pack as a
prerequisite yeah well yeah I think I I
think that is an interesting question
and I'm glad that we've answered and I
feel like Maggie don't don't let it get
in don't let it get in the way don't let
that wall of ABS interfere with this
productive relationship that you're
having with a nice young man this
question comes from Doug who asks dear
Hank and John my six-year-old told me
that he wants to have a dude's day and
I'm excited that he wants to have a
father/son day but the problem is that
we seem to have different ideas about
what exactly we should do on a dudes day
my idea is to spend the afternoon
teaching him how to change the oil on my
Jeep we can bond while I teach him an
important skill that my father taught me
a bit like when you were six there not
when you were six man his idea is
suspend today playing games and eating
pizza in the company of a giant rodent
what should we do come on man Doug yeah
Doug I mean here yeah the answer of
course is that you got to change that
oil I mean that's a it's a no-brainer
yeah Chucky Chucky Cheese is a it is a
contaminant nightmare I mean is you want
to talk about places that I don't want
to see a black light applied to just you
turn that you turn the black light on
and at Chuck E Cheese and you're at a
rave
yeah patient zero for every plague he's
chuck-e-cheese like that animal yeah I
mean so Doug I get it man like I have to
take my kids to Chuck E Cheese a lot and
like the people who work at Chuck E
Cheese are really nice and I think they
have a hard job and so I don't want to
say anything bad about Chuck E Cheese
but it's I mean though like the the
number of stimulants the number of like
just things that are happening at Chuck
E Cheese per minute I was actually
recently at Chuck E Cheese Hank and you
know what I was thinking I was thinking
there is absolutely no analog for this
in the natural world before like 70 or
80 years ago no human being had ever
experienced what I'm experiencing right
now it's like kind of like a casino
because there's a lot of noise is
happening the carpet is is dirty and
very colorful and then there's like a
lot of just like sort of like
blank-faced people staring into games
hitting buttons over and over again
except instead of it being gamblers it's
children and they're just trying to
they're just trying to win enough
tickets to get you know some sweet tarts
and uh I was trying to think like maybe
like as did a human being before like
about 1910 ever experienced anything
like being inside of a Chucky Cheese
ever and maybe like some once somebody
was swimming and like
a huge number of swordfish swam around
them and sort of like attacked them all
at the same time and then disappeared
and maybe that was like a brief moment
of like chuck-e-cheese this but like
there is no analog for it in the actual
lived world pre-1920
and I think that says a lot about how
stressful it is for a lot of people
especially like it's definitely
stressful for me
so I get it so what you have to do is
you're gonna pretend your kids gonna
pretend to be interested in changing the
oil for an hour you're gonna like try to
teach them they're not going to learn
anything and then the whole time they're
gonna be like is it time yet is it time
yet is it time yet and you'll be like no
we've got to finish this and then when
you finish it then you have to take them
to Chuckie Cheese it's a both/and
situation not an either/or situation I
mean definitely like the idea that you
would do either of these things without
pizza is just ludicrous actually the
pizza Chuckie Cheese is pretty good yeah
so like even if you like you gotta you
gotta even if you're changing the oil
you should do that while eating pizza in
the company of a giant rodent I don't
know where you're gonna get the giant
rodent but obviously that's a that's
important part of the childhood
experience so get one that's terrible
advice from somebody who has a
six-month-old uh yeah I mean he's
basically kind of like a giant rodent
now your kid yeah he's a very big no
he's not it's like actually you know
skilled as a rodent no I would argue
though that he's also much larger than
any any living rodent well that is like
that is demonstrable yeun true Jon there
are many many very large room please
don't I don't actually you know what I'd
have no desire whatsoever to learn about
rodents that weigh more than ten pounds
ever period end of story but move on to
the next question this question comes
from Alyssa who asks dear John and Hank
this is more of a question for Hank but
if there is an earthquake on Mars would
it still be considered an earthquake oh
so that comes to the question of whether
we're calling the ground of Mars Earth
in the way that we call the ground we
already have discussed on a previous of
the podcast we made we've made too many
of these things so but no I think you
would I know for a fact that
our earthquakes on the moon and we call
the moon quakes so I imagine that
earthquakes that take place on Mars are
called Mars quakes boo oh God
it's over all right man we're gonna get
through all the questions it seems
unlikely okay John final question before
we move on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon's question is from Ryan an
actual Ryan who asks dear Hank and John
my name is Ryan
I have enrolled and will attend my State
University in the fall and a few of my
friends from high school are also going
I plan to be roommates with my best
friend Ryan first oh my god that's
amazing I don't I don't know if I
believe it my question is do you think I
should try to maintain my circle of
friends or start over and try to meet
new people in college don't forget to be
Ryan Ryan that's such a Ryan way to
write an email to he put 5 Ryan's very
Ryan said in C mail um yeah I mean
obviously if your best friend is named
Ryan and you're gonna be roommates like
you're doing a pretty good job of
figuring out who your friend should be
you're crushing it on the Ryan front and
I would say that you probably just want
to keep going trying to meet as many
Ryan's as you can and make it into a
thing like maybe you guys could form
some kind of like fraternity or social
organization like race right Ryan's
specific right yep there's a lot of you
guys I I will say like it can be easy to
get sucked into and stick with the same
like comfortable social group even if
like you are aware that you aren't
seeing the full possibility or having
the full range of human connections that
you might be having at a college and and
that it is good to try and connect
people who are in the same program as
you or in the same classes as you or
into the same things as you and and but
managing that is hard
managing like multiple friend groups and
like having an established one and and
then and then sort of like how much time
do I spend with my old friends versus my
new friends and that's like it's so
legit it's a legit thing that you will
struggle with and I just say like know
that it's a struggle but it's worthwhile
to do yeah I didn't know anybody there
was one guy from my high school who went
to my
College and we stayed friends but but it
was only one guy so it wasn't it wasn't
your best friend Ryan it was not no it
was not a Ryan Hank before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon very
quickly I just want to read this amazing
email from Jennifer who writes Dear John
and Hank after hearing the story of Emma
and her dilemma that was a woman whose
name is Emma but with three M's because
of a typographical error made by a
careless county clerk somewhere I needed
to share my brother is named Benjamin
not Benjamin Benjamin as his big sister
I've often been asked why this is our
mother had the flu when she gave birth
and our Father was at work so an ill
mother gave my brother his name and he
has never changed it Benjamin Benjamin
is actually a pretty cool name it's much
I have to say Benjamin is much better
that seems like particular and specific
in a way that Emma just seems like a
mistake I don't know man
I don't know I'm a nan the side of
keeping that third end because what else
what else do you have
you have presumably like the rest of
your life okay first first let's get to
the news from AFC Wimbledon because it's
extremely important AFC Wimbledon Hank
as you you will remember the last time
that we recorded a podcast together AFC
Wimbledon had not scored a goal in the
month of April and they had one game
remaining against Oldham and it didn't
matter from the perspective of staying
up because they'd already secured enough
points to stay up all they need but but
they did want to score a goal in April
because otherwise it would have been
impossible to have a best goal of April
celebration on account of how there were
no goals in April despite playing one
two three four five six games in April
but what happened instead of scoring a
goal is a nil nil draw super-exciting
complete the mother of April worked it
up to complete the month of April goal
this heroic and extremely rare feat for
a football club to play six games with
no goals that means that for the last I
540 minutes of AFC Wimbledon season no
goals but it doesn't matter AFC
Wimbledon staying up in Ligue 1
it's an incredible accomplishment they
finished the season 15th in Ligue 1 just
below middle of the table a really
extraordinary accomplishment for a team
with one of the smallest budgets in the
league and the smallest stadium in the
league so I am happy and excited and
excited to move forward into the
offseason we call this the silly season
Hank because it's when all the trade
rumors start happening and it's very
very exciting
well I yeah I mean I don't know if you
listened to last week's podcast but
maíam had a bunch of information on some
players that you were definitely losing
yeah which hopefully will free up some
some capital for the acquisition of new
folk yeah yeah no I think the big one is
the goalkeeper James Shay yeah but uh
but it's it's what what was what was
that about why you gotta get rid of
James Shay money I think it's about too
it was too expensive or III well I don't
know I listen I really don't know and
they didn't say but from everything that
I've heard he is a consummate
professional and extremely well-liked
and and a really great guy and hopefully
we'll land on his feet somewhere it's
like the nature of football though man
it is really hard to stay at a team for
a long time these days what's the news
from Mars so you know how on the surface
of Mars there's a lot of radiation
because it doesn't have a magnetic field
to protect the surface from the sun's
the sun's harmful rays oh yeah well
there are some places here on the
surface of Earth that also have a lot of
radiation and and we are looking at
those places to see how things manage to
live there despite the tremendous not
just - despite but but but also have
evolved to live in places where it would
be very difficult to live if you didn't
have some kind of protection from
radiation those places being former
nuclear reactors that went critical
so Chernobyl and and the one in and and
Fukushima right which I almost forgot
the name of it's okay so Chernobyl and
Fukushima are two places where you're
like life
should stay away from that but there are
there are some species that have evolved
to be able to live there and seem to
have some have evolved some traits that
make them resistant to radiation
particularly a fungus so this is true of
a bigger complex organisms like mice -
but but this fungus it seems to even
prefer to be around radiation and we
don't know if it prefers it or if it's
just that the niche is open and so it
moves on in because it's it capable of
dealing with it
but there was just a year-long
experiment on the ISS looking at this
mold and and some other and some other
fungi sorry I have a cold had a cold I'm
getting over it so that there was just
an experiment on the International Space
Station looking at a bunch of different
molds that have evolved to do well in
the presence of a lot of radiation one
to see how they might function on the
surface of Mars - to see what kinds of
adaptations life on other planets that
don't have a strong magnetic field might
need to have and three to maybe help get
the powers of those molds either into
people or helping people and that might
be in the form of like a long time from
now like genetic modification or in
creating some kind of like fungi based
sun block to protect humans from the the
harmful effects of long-term exposure to
radiation which they would undergo both
on the surface of Mars and on the way
there and back so you were yourself in
fungus to get ready for the your big
Mars trip yeah and the fungus would be
like awesome hit me with that radiation
man Wow
I mean that makes me want to go to Mars
so one of the things that they're
thinking about doing is radiation
resistant jeans this is what the
scientist said can be incorporated into
yeast cells that produce beer so that
humans are willing to go to space they
will have better beer to drink and that
might even protect you from radiation
well actually it canceled them back in
alright Hank we all go we have to go
record our bonus podcast this weekend
rye
but what did we learn today well before
we get to that I just want to say that
if you want to subscribe to this weekend
Ryan's you can do so by supporting this
podcast $5.00 a month
help us help us stay real sponsor free
just kidding we're desperately waiting
for those real sponsors to come on board
but you can over at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John every week we talk
about Orion Hank who's our Ryan this
week are we are we ruining it are we
ruining the surprise no it's not a ruin
of the surprise because the listeners to
this weekend Ryan actually get it
slightly before they get dear Hank and
John oh okay oh that this weeks of Ryan
I think John is gonna be Rihanna
it's brilliant Hank it's that mean it's
your greatest work it's your magnum opus
it's your cobbler calm I mean of this
weekend Ryan's alright what did we learn
today well of course we learned that
copy or calm is totally a thing that you
can go to right now and totally buy
stuff on we learned that you can eat a
lot of tacos and still have a boyfriend
with a six-pack and of course we learned
that you you to when you grow up if you
work hard and play your cards right and
get a little lucky might end up a
celebrity and finally we learned that
John really does not want to know about
the existence of 200-pound rodents that
live in South America their copy barrage
on they're super cute you should check
their is not a 200-pound rodent on this
earth is there really there's a bunch of
them of good lord save me
thanks for potting with me Hank and also
for doing that thing that I specifically
asked you not to do yeah this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our social media manager is
Victoria Bongiorno
music is from the great gunnarolla you
can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com where we will answer your
questions John and I are also on Twitter
at Hank green and at John Green and
other places on the Internet we are
always excited to see you if you'd like
to support the podcast and also get this
week in Ryan's which is our short Ryan
Bay
Podcast you can do that at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]